i never touched anyone inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
i did not have sexual relations with
that woman
give that man a cigar
[Music]
[Applause]
happy tuesday so do you remember
newton's law
not that newton this newton
not that newton this newton there we go
that went over really well isaac newton
once said that for every action there's
an equal and opposite reaction meaning
much like my nightly massage therapists
forces always come in pairs and in this
case it's fear and a response to fear
firearm sales have soared during the
crime wave creating an ammunition
shortage
of course not among the gangs of chicago
and new york city
but the bullet shortage is so bad gang
bangers have agreed to limit their
shootings
to bystanders who aren't vaccinated
as firearms sales jumped by over 20
million last year with over 8 million
new purchases the ammo
started running out and now firearm
instructors are so short on ammo
they're cancelling their courses which
sucks for new shooters like me yes
so if you're surprised by this then you
must be surprised by
sunrises or tax day or how dumb joy
behar is any
that gets applause i got to remember
that and
anyone with half a brain could see this
coming
or half a brain in total
the run on guns is a direct response to
a legitimate fear it's no different than
the sales increase in plywood
during and after the riots but oddly the
fear isn't stoked by the media hysteria
which is usually the case they'll get
worked they'll get you worked up over
any imaginary crisis like sharks or
fried eggs or sharks frying eggs but
growing
violent crime you hear crickets instead
it's the media's denial that fuels the
gun
mania the media is no different than
hunter biden saying
what drug problem but turn on the local
news and it's all
there a woman gets sucker punched on the
street 10 people shot over a weekend in
a big city
another woman dies after a brutal
mugging every day it's a new story
that adds to the chilling statistics
meanwhile the national news runs
from the story like a female staffer
running from andrew cuomo
and and that creepy denial creates more
suspicion like these crime waves are
somehow
acceptable because it's fine with the
ruling class and their well-armed
security
not a lot of street crime at a party in
martha's vineyard but if martha owned a
convenience store in baltimore she's out
of luck
and yet the media tells you you're nuts
to think violence is happening even when
you see it with your own eyes
and that has people like me buying guns
for protection can you imagine
i can't go on certain carnival rides but
me buying a tactical shotgun
is a snap i love this country
and the media makes sure this trend is
not going to stop the gun store shelves
are now as empty as cats medicine
cabinet after a long weekend
and for once the media can't blame
right-wing media or the nra or even
trump
like the blood of a gunshot victim it's
kind of on them the media is mocking
denial of
crime statistics the cheering of police
defunding while dismissing the threat to
small business owners often
minorities is fueling this rise
including
among law-abiding women and minorities
they're buying the guns
finally diversity is a tool for good
it's about time
it's gut felt's rule number 33 buying a
gun is a gateway drug to leaving leftism
gun ownership leads to immediate wisdom
it's like the time you saw what damage
fica did to your first paycheck oh
if you don't know what that means then
you're not working meanwhile the media
and the dems will drive gun purchases up
even more
smith and wesson should be sending a
whitman sampler to cnn
it's a cheap chocolate instead of
focusing on the bad guys however the
media will use the vague phrase gun
violence
to nationalize the issue while calling
crime a local issue
weird it's incompatible and it's
malicious it's an epidemic they'll say
lumping all gun owners and illegal gun
owners into the same group
but when is the last time you saw a
gang-banger with a 10-point buck tied to
the roof of their escalade
it's like saying drinking a glass of
water is harmful since other people are
drowning in the ocean
the common denominator is water but
that's idiotic
so rather than focus on the criminal
they shall focus on the law abiding
which is like remaking jaws with
swimmers as the bad guys
why do that because it's easier law
abiding people actually will abide by
the laws that are made and criminals
they won't they're criminals so today's
lawmakers just make it easier for
themselves by making shoplifting and
retail theft card chases
and assault unworthy of arrest it's all
part of a greater mission
to remake society into something new by
destroying it first
and what does that do well newton also
said what goes up
must come down the more the dems and the
media try to reduce your security
it's up to the rest of us to enhance it
at this rate by 2022 we'll all be
driving tanks
let's welcome tonight's guests
she's so southern she brushes her teeth
with gravy
boss business news anchor dagon mcdowell
he's more inflammatory than smoking at a
gas station
outkick.com founder and foster's
contributor clay travis
she's like a moth drawn to bright lights
and chewing holes and sweaters
fox news contributor cat tip
and it's a federal crime for him to hop
on a pogo stick
my massive side kick in hosted upside
front station iris
digging yes sir so the story came out
this week we're running out of ammo
and people who aren't familiar with guns
are like well how much ammo
ammo or ammo
says that the ammo people think you
don't need that much but the fact is you
need a lot of ammo because ammo makes
better
shooters for training purposes a huge
concern
with the more than eight million new gun
owners who um
bought purchased weapons or multiple
weapons potentially last year
you need to be able to go to the range
and learn how to shoot
but where i come from if you don't have
a massive stockpile of ammo
that is a plague on your house that is a
pox on your family
yes that uh it's like wearing thigh high
boots to church
or saying that barbecue the barbecue in
brooklyn is awesome
like you're like they lock the door when
you show up if that's the way you roll
like if you ask call up a friend and ask
them to ask them for some extra ammo
they'll tell you to go camp out in a
tent
out in front of the gun store for it uh
which is actually happening i thought it
would be the equivalent if i walked over
to one of my neighbors
uh in westchester with a cup and asked
for bullets they might give it to me
like do you have any spare bullets
just like sugar no they don't own
guns in west and now they're going to
set their alarm even when
you know they see you in your yard
they're going to set the alarm on your
on their house i have it really quickly
i have an ammo update for you sure
please tell us
i actually got a lot of my friends on
the phone for this
the shortages are easing for common
caliber ammunition
nine millimeter 380 45 and 556.
prices are still high greg where's the
damn green screen ammo manufacturers are
pre-ordered for
18 to 24 months back ordered remington
back online in the spring that's good
news six hours expanding an ammo plant
in arkansas
that might take a year but you're going
to have more supply coming on and it was
all about a primer shortage so it wasn't
about lead or raw materials
there you go there's your ammo report
clay i think that means none of us have
to recycle our bullets
well that's positive look i also was
raised in the south and they give you
guns at
early ages which a lot of people in
other parts of the country think is
crazy right you're eight nine years old
holding a gun learning how to fire it
but the best possible boon for firearm
cells and bullet cells has been
the absolutely absurdly ridiculous
argument to defund the police where
everybody out there
who has a functional brain knew what was
going to happen crime was going to
skyrocket
criminals don't follow gun laws already
changing them doesn't help
and so a lot of people have decided we
have to protect ourselves and even
people as you mentioned eight million
new gun owners people who would have
never considered westchester
buying guns it's happening everywhere
and uh i don't see any why
any reason why it's gonna suddenly ease
i think the demand is only gonna
continue to grow
yeah i think so too now the last time we
did a segment on guns i asked you how
many guns you had
has that a number of guns increased
since that was two weeks ago
yes yes unfortunately yes i'm a proud
new daddy of a
a pistol grip shotgun oh wow yeah it's
pretty sweet like it's
phenomenal you know what else is
phenomenal is you know there's times in
life when
working for fox news you sometimes get
the chagrin or the you know the dirty
look or something like that
not in a gun store literally uh they're
like tyrus is here
we have some things in the back
and it's real tall and here's the deal
there was a long line for ammunition
the guy's doing anything and he's like
tyrus yeah
you know and he's like how many boxes do
you need and then i come back with how
much you got
yeah he's like taller than you so you
know and i walk with my truck with my
heavy artillery but it's in
i have to thank the left i have to think
you defund the police you finance the
nra and every gun shop owner
especially small time owners were
feeling the pinch they were shutting
down in my
in mandeville louisiana there was two
gun shops that closed down
because they just weren't doing enough
business they're back now yeah yeah
because you defunded the police
which means we got to start thinking
about raising militias just to
walk through our streets and keep things
safe that's what you force people to do
so i've learned that ammo is very
precious cat it's a very precious thing
you um what do you stand on this is this
a good
development or a bad development or just
a development
i mean it's a development i i would go
so far as to say that
uh i think that look i think that more
people um having
you know becoming first-time gun buyers
is a good thing uh i think that they
maybe understand
oh like i actually should be able to
protect myself in any situation
but also the bad thing would be that in
this situation
you've truly been given no choice right
because the lawmakers in some of these
cities
removing police protection while also
hiring you know private security or
using police for themselves in their own
homes
you start to sit back and think huh
through that maybe they were feeding me
some
and then you buy a gun so the that led
to it is bad but i think people
opening up their eyes to the you know
second amendment is a good thing
especially i mean hearing that more
women are purchasing guns is like a very
is a very good sign learning to use it
and trying to get
trying to get pat beyond that bur that i
don't know that
barrier that they're just hesitant
because it's a guy thing
it's not a some of the best shooters
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else